L
BLOW YOUR MIND.
IT IS ON FOX NATION AND HERE IS
JOHN.
>> Sean: WELCOME YOU TO
"HANNITY."
>> Announcer: AMERICANS HELD
HOSTAGE.
BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
844.
>> Sean: AMERICANS HELD
HOSTAGE 44 DAYS BEHIND EMILY --
ENEMY LINES.
HUNDREDS OF AMERICANS, OR LEGAL
RESIDENTS WITH GREEN CARDS.
ALL OF THEIR FAMILIES, THOUSANDS
OF AFGHAN ALLIES.
THEY REMAIN ABANDONED BEHIND
EMILY LINES.
JOE BIDEN HAS TURNED THE PAGE.
WE WILL NOT FORGET.
SADLY THE SITUATION ON THE
GROUND GETS WORSE EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
TALIBAN TERRITORIES ARE NOT ONCE
AGAIN HANGING PEOPLE IN THE
PUBLIC SQUARE.
BUT THEY ARE DOING IT VERY
PROFESSIONALLY AND BUSINESSLIKE.
ACCORDING TO BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
INCLUDING ONE MAN WHO HAS
REPORTEDLY SPRUNG UP FROM A TALL
CRANE BREAK IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
CITY, PROFESSIONAL BUSINESSLIKE.
WE TURN THE PAGE.
TO.
AS WE SPEAK TO ANYONE WHO
ASSISTED THE U.S. IN ANY WAY IS
BEING HUNTED DOWN AND WILL SOON
FACE A SIMILAR FATE.
JOE BIDEN DID NOT -- IS NOT
WORKING AT ALL TO LIFT A FINGER
TO RESCUE OUR FELLOW CITIZENS.
IN FACT, HE IS BARELY WORKING ON
ANYTHING AT ALL.
LAST WEEK, FOUR DAYS ON THE JOB,
SHE IS OFF TO CAMP DAVID.
2:48 P.M. AND DEEP AFTERNOON.
AFTER REFUSING TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT AFGHANISTAN.
THE CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
BEGGING OPEC FOR MORE OIL
PRODUCTION.
YOU LOOK AT THE USUAL THINGS
THAT HE'D IGNORE SORT OF
HORRIFIC STATE OF THE ECONOMY.
TAKE A LOOK.
[INDISTINCT QUESTION]
>> President Biden: IT MAY NOT
BE BY THE NOT BE BY THE END OF
THE WEEK.
I HOPE IT IS BY THE END OF THE
WEEK.
AS LONG AS THEY ARE STILL ALIVE,
GOT THREE THINGS TO DO.
RESOLUTION AND THE TWO PIECES OF
LEGISLATION.
IF WE DO THAT, THE COUNTRY IS
GOING TO BE IN GREAT SHAPE.
[INDISTINCT QUESTION]
>> Sean: HE JUST WALKS OFF
LIKE A ROBOT BUT HE GETS YELLED
AT.
INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING THE CRISIS
AT THE BORDER, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OR OUTRIGHT LYING
DEFLECTING, COPING, THE CRISIS
WILL MAGICALLY RESOLVE ITSELF
LIKE AFGHANISTAN, WE JUST WON'T
PAY ATTENTION ANYMORE.
JOE BIDEN THINKS HE DID A GREAT
JOB IN AFGHANISTAN BUT HE DID
NOT.
THE SAME WITH THE BORDER.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN MARCH, BIDEN'S
HELMET SECURITY SECRETARY
ALEJANDRO PROCLAIMED THE BORDER
IT WAS CLOSED AND HE SAID, WE
ARE EXPELLING THE FAMILIES.
WE ARE EXPELLING SINGLE ADULTS.
HE WAS LYING TO YOU, YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE FOLLOWING MONTHS, MORE THAN
A MILLION AND A HALF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS HAVE CROSSED THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY AND OF COURSE,
MAY YOUR KISS -- MAYORKAS
REFUSES TO SAVE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT TO KEEP USE THE WORD
"NONCITIZENS."
THESE UNDOCUMENTED NONCITIZENS
OR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE -- OR
ALIENS HAVE BEEN DISPERSED ALL
OVER THE U.S. WITH LITTLE TO
KNOW THAT IN.
FOR EXAMPLE, ALMOST EVERYONE IN
THE RECENT WAVE OF HAITIAN
MIGRANTS, THEY WERE ADMITTED
INTO THE U.S. WITHOUT SO MUCH AS
A SIMPLE COVID TEST.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE HERE
VERY LONG.
THAT WILL BE ANOTHER LIE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW MANY HAVE BEEN PLACED
INTO THE U.S.?
>> THEY ARE RELEASED ON
CONDITIONS.
I THINK IT IS ABOUT 10,000 OR
SO.
12,000.
>> HAVE BEEN RELEASED?
>> YES.
>> END OF THE 5,000 THAT HAVE --
>> WE WILL MAKE DETERMINATIONS
WHETHER THEY WILL BE RETURNED.
TO HAITI.
BASED ON OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PUBLIC INTEREST AUTHORITIES.
>> ARE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
TOTAL OF 12,000 OR COULD IT BE
EVEN CHIROPRACTIC.
>> IT COULD BE EVEN HIGHER.
THE NUMBER OF RETURN COULD BE
EVEN HIGHER.
>> Sean: I WANT TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT ONE THING.
I AM 100% PRO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
I'M ALL FOR IT.
MY GRANDPARENTS CAME HERE FROM
IRELAND.
THEY WERE DIRT POOR.
BOTH MY PARENTS GREW UP WITH
NEXT TO NOTHING.
THEY FACED DISCRIMINATION AT THE
TIME.
AND I KNEW -- I KNOW I STAND ON
THEIR SHOULDERS.
AND I'M GRATEFUL.
NOW, IF YOU ARE AN IMMIGRANT, I
WILL BE VERY HONEST, I DON'T
CARE WHAT COUNTRY YOU COME FROM,
WHAT CONTINENT YOU COME FROM, I
CAN.
WHAT YOU SOUND LIKE, WHAT YOU
LOOK LIKE, WE ARE ALL GOD'S
CHILDREN.
NO COUNTRY ON EARTH IS WITHOUT
BORDERS.
PEOPLE HAVE GOT TO RESPECT OUR
LAWS, OUR BORDERS, AND OUR
SOVEREIGNTY, PERIOD, AND NO
EXCEPTIONS.
WHEAT MUST BE A NATION OF LAWS.
IN FACT TOOK MOST COUNTRIES ARE
VERY STRICT IMMIGRATION LAWS.
LOOK AT THIS.
INDUSTRIAL LOOK AT THE ASYLUM
SEEKERS, THEY ARE NOT EVEN
ALLOWED ONSHORE.
THEY WILL STOP YOU AND THEY WILL
TAKE YOU TO A, IN A DIFFERENT
ISLAND.
THEY WILL GIVE YOU FOOD AND
WATER AND MEDICAL ASSISTANCE IF
YOU NEEDED.
AND THEN THEY WILL SEND YOU
HOME.
IT IS SO DIFFICULT FOR THESE
REFUGES THAT ULTIMATELY
EMIGRATED TO AUSTRALIA.
THE U.S., THEY HAVE BEEN
RESETTLING AUSTRALIAN BOUND
MIGRANTS AND OFFSHORE SEVEN
CAMPS NEAR AUSTRALIA'S MAN IN.
THEY REFUSED TO TAKE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THEY UPHOLD THE LAW IN THEIR
COUNTRY.
IN WESTERN EUROPE, YOU HAVE
RECORD HYBRID 21,000
ASYLUM-SEEKERS IN 2015.
DENMARK SAID ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
THEY TOOK STEPS TO STOP AND
PROCESSED MIGRANTS AGAINST
OFFSHORE.
MANY OTHER COUNTRIES, YOU KNOW,
CITIZENSHIP IS SUCH A HIGH WORTH
IMMIGRANTS WILL PAY AND PURCHASE
CITIZENSHIP.
BY THE WAY, SOME AMERICANS, TO
GIVE UP THEIR CITIZENSHIP AND BY
CITIZENSHIP, OTHER COUNTRIES.
WHY?
CITIZENSHIP ESPECIALLY TO THIS
COUNTRY IS OF GREAT VALUE.
FOR PEOPLE COMING FROM COUNTRIES
THAT DO NOT HAVE THE FREEDOMS WE
OFTEN TAKE FOR GRANTED.
A BOOK YOU LOOK AT ST. LUCIA FOR
EXAMPLE.
ROUGHLY ABOUT 250 GRAND.
YOU CAN GET A PASSPORT AND BE A
CITIZEN.
AND ANTIGO KIRK BUDA, IT IS
ABOUT LIVER -- A LITTLE UNDER
POST-CYPRUS IS ASKING A BUMPING
INTO AN HALF-MILLION.
THEY CALLED THEM DONATIONS AND
INVESTMENTS AND YOU CAN BUY
CITIZENSHIP.
IN NEW ZEALAND, YOU GOT TO
INVEST $2 MILLION OVER FOUR
YEARS AND BE THERE ARE X NUMBER
OF DAYS.
AND 1.1 MILLION.
CONVICTED -- IN INVESTMENTS AND
DONATIONS.
EVEN CANADIAN RESIDENCY,
ENCOURAGES RESIDENCY FOR A FEW
HUNDRED THOUSAND BUCKS WORTH OF
GOVERNMENT BONDS.
CITIZENSHIP IS A VALUABLE
COVETED THING ALL AROUND THE
GLOBE.
AMERICA THE GREATEST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD.
HOW MUCH WOULD PEOPLE PAY TO BE
USES IN HERE?
MAYBE WE SHOULD ALSO GET IN ON
THIS ACTION AND MAY BE CHARGED
PEOPLE TO BE CITIZENS EVERY
OTHER COUNTRY APPEARS TO BE
DOING IT.
HERE IN THE U.S., WHERE WE LET
IN MORE IMMIGRANTS THAN ANYWHERE
ELSE ON EARTH, WE DON'T ASK FOR
A PENNY.
INSTEAD IN THEORY, WE MERELY ASK
IMMIGRANTS TO FOLLOW OUR LAWS
AND WE NEED TO DO MORE.
FOR EXAMPLE, I DON'T CARE WHERE
YOU CAN FROM.
EVERYBODY COME INTO THIS COUNTRY
SHOULD UNDERGO A SECURITY
SPREADING TO THE METRIC DON'T
MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS.
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC THAT
WOULD BE A BREAK WISE THING TO
MAKE SURE WE DO A HEALTH VETTING
SO YOU ARE NOT COVERED POSITIVE
OR DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER DISEASE.
IN MOST CASES, IMMIGRANTS ALSO
SHOULD PROVE HAVE THE ABILITY,
IF WE ARE GENEROUS ENOUGH TO
INVITE THEM INTO THAT THEY HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES FINANCIALLY AND NOT
BE A BURDEN ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
OF WE CANNOT PUT THAT BURDEN.
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO PUT THAT
BURDEN ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I.D. LOOK AT THAT WOULD ALSO
POSSESS A COVETED SKILL OR A
TRADE.
WE CAN'T DRIVE THE WAGES OF
AMERICAN WORKERS DOWN EITHER.
UNFORTUNATELY, DEMOCRATS BLOCK
DONALD TRUMP'S MERIT-BASED
IMMIGRATION BILL LIKE THEY HAVE
IN COUNTRIES LIKE AUSTRALIA.
NOW JOE BIDEN IS REFUSING TO
ENFORCE ANY OF OUR EXISTING
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
HE IS NOT ONLY ENFORCING THE
LAWS.
HE IS AIDING AND ABETTING THE
LAW, BREAKING.
WHICH HE SWORE NOT TO DO.
NO BACKGROUND CHECKS, NO HEALTH
CHECKS.
MANY ARE HUGE FINANCIAL BURDEN
TO YOU, THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER
BUT WE CAN'T AFFORD JOE BIDEN'S
OPEN BORDERS AND LAWLESSNESS.
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER IS A
FREE-FOR-ALL.
HE HAS MADE IT THAT WAY.
THE ADMINISTRATION -- NOT KNOW
EXACTLY WHO THEY ARE LETTING IN.
A FUTURE REQUESTED COURT DAY.
THAT IS A REQUESTED COURT DAY.
THEY DON'T EVEN REQUIRE YOU TO
APPEAR NOW UNDER JOE BIDEN.
AND OTHER RISK MOST IMMIGRANTS
ARE NOT GOING TO ABIDE BY THAT
REQUEST BUT THEY DON'T HAVE TO.
THIS HAS MASSIVE SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS.
AND JOE BIDEN STATED IN THE
2007, MUCH DIFFERENT JOE BIDEN
WE SEE TODAY, NO COUNTRY CAN BE
SECURED WITHOUT CONTROLLING
THEIR BORDERS.
LET'S LISTEN TO JOKE BACK IN THE
GOOD OLD DAYS.
>> President Biden: WHAT DO I
THINK ABOUT THE CONTROL OF OUR
BORDERS?
WHAT WOULD I DO ABOUT IT?
NO GREAT COUNTRY CAN SAY IT IS
SECURE WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO
CONTROL ITS BORDERS.
PERIOD.
WHAT I WOULD DO ABOUT IT, WHAT I
PROPOSE TO DO ABOUT IT, ALMOST
13 YEARS AGO.
I WOULD RADICALLY RAMP UP THE
NUMBER OF BORDER SECURITY GUARDS
WE HAVE THE USE OF ELECTRONIC
SURVEILLANCE MATERIAL WE HAVE TO
THE GUARD THE BORDER, AND THE
NUMBER OF WHAT THEY CALL VIRTUAL
FENCES.
>> Sean: THAT IS THE JOE BIDEN
WE SEE TODAY.
LOOKS PRETTY WEAK, FRAIL AND IS
A MESS.
BUT THAT IS A SIDESHOW.
AND PARTIALLY BIDEN CARES LESS
ABOUT A SECURE AMERICA AND MORE
ABOUT RADICAL SOCIALIST BASE
THAT IS THE MODERN DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY.
BECAUSE THAT SOCIALIST BASE,
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN BORDERS
AND NOR DO THEY PUT ANY VALUE ON
IT.
THEY WANT A COMPLETE CONFEDERATE
IMMIGRATION NO MATTER WHAT.
NOW, WHY ASK YOURSELF THE
DEMOCRATS, THEY TRIED TO SNEAK
AMNESTY INTO THE TENANT
RECONCILIATION BILL.
FREE CITIZENSHIP UNTIL THE
SENATE PARLIAMENTARIAN STEPPED
IN.
SOMETHING OF GREAT VALUE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
IS IT THEIR HOPE THAT, OKAY WE
ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU SOMETHING
THAT OTHER COUNTRIES CHARGE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS IF NOT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR.
WE WILL GIVE IT TO YOU, BUT YOU
ARE GOING TO VOTE DEMOCRAT,
RIGHT?
AND YOU ARE NOT GOING TO PUT FOR
THOSE MEAN OLD REPUBLICANS THAT
FOLLOWED THAT LAW AND BELIEVE
THAT YOU SHOULD RESPECT OUR LAW
AND OUR SOVEREIGNTY AND OUR
BORDERS.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO VOTE FOR
THEM.
I DON'T CARE WHERE YOU COME
FROM.
FORGET THE MASS MIGRATION DRIVE
DOWN WAGES FOR LOW INCOME
WORKERS, SECURITY IMPLICATIONS,
FORGET THE ABUSE, THE RAPE, THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THROUGH MEXICO
AND OTHER COUNTRIES.
FORGET THE MASS MIGRATION DRIVES
DOWN QUALITIES WAGES, ET CETERA,
ET CETERA.
ALL OF THIS, YOU KNOW, IS DONE
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
JOE BIDEN HAS NO CLUE.
APPARENTLY NONE OF THESE THINGS
MATTER TO THE RADICAL LEFT.
INSTEAD OF SECURING THE BORDER
AND TELLING MIGRANTS NOT TO
COME, IF BIDEN IS DEFLECTING.
HE IS LYING AND BLAMING EVERYONE
ELSE, ESPECIALLY DONALD TRUMP.
BLAMING THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS
ON HORSEBACK.
FALSELY ACCUSING THEM OF
WHIPPING MIGRANTS.
EVEN THE PHOTOGRAPHER THAT TOOK
THE PICTURE SAID THAT DID NOT
HAPPEN.
THAT IS A LIFE.
NOW, THE BORDER PATROL UNION,
THE AGENTS ARE FIGHTING BACK AND
THEY ARE DEMANDING AN APOLOGY.
HE IS BLAMING CONGRESS FOR NOT
PASSING COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
JOE, WHO ARE THE PRESIDENT.
YOU GET IT DONE.
YOU HAVE BOTH HOUSES OF
CONGRESS.
YOUR PARTY RUNS THE WHOLE SHOW.
DONALD TRUMP CONTROLLED THE
BORDERS.
WE HAD A 40-YEAR LOW OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE HE PUT IN
PLACE MEASURES LIKE BUILDING A
PORTABLE, STAY IN MEXICO POLICY,
ENDING CATCH AND RELEASE, WHICH
YOU HAVE NOW TURNED INTO PROCESS
AND BELIZE.
ALL OF THIS AND MORE.
BIDEN HAS ALSO BLAMED FROM
BARCLAYS TRUMP FOR HANDING HIM A
MESS.
NO, HE HAD A CUTE SECURED
BORDERS.
HE HEADED YOU IN ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
AFGHANISTAN THAT WAS SECURE.
AND JOE EVEN CLAIMED THAT
WEATHER, CLAIMING THAT TOOK
MIGRANT SURGE WAS SEASONAL.
IT ACTUALLY GOT WORSE.
I CAN REPORT THAT MIGRANT SURGE
DID NOT E